and joining me now is Ben Shapiro
editor-in-chief of The Daily wire and
host of the Ben Shapiro show whose
special episode to commemorate the 75th
anniversary of d-day is now available on
daily wired.com and it's fantastic so
then which action is more troubling here
what The Daily Beast did or that
Facebook just handed over his name
because what the daily be is called let
me I'm certainly disturbed that Facebook
was handing this stuff over you have to
expect the Daily Beast to be the Daily
Beast and unfortunately their media
outlets that as you know Laura are
motivated to take down anybody who
happens to be right of center no matter
who they are no matter whether they wish
to remain anonymous no matter whether
all they did was just posted a YouTube
video the fact that Facebook handed over
the information is truly incredible my
impression was that if you are posting
anonymously at Facebook that it's not
really within Facebook's purview to
start handing out that information to
media outlets but I guess that that
isn't true
Ben what this really is we have to be
really clear about this this is just one
more step toward silencing of opposing
voices it will focus on the horrible
aspect of daxing someone revealing their
identity the guy is not someone who has
any money he's a day laborer we haven't
independently confirmed every detail
about him but it's a guy doesn't have a
lot and so they make him escape but this
is a warning shot is it not Ben they
they try to go after you know this
program they go after other programs go
after other websites demonize them to
silence them especially when they're
beaten in the ratings night after night
okay so but that's really what this is
all about there's no question I mean the
fact that the live the left the media
left are intent on destroying all
opposition all the way down to some
random guy who drives a forklift and
posted a funny video of Nancy Pelosi it
just shows how how vile and and angry
the left has become about taking out
people who opposed them in any way I
mean that this is just the the ultimate
example of that but as you mentioned
obviously everybody who is who is in the
conservative media has become a target
for the left and left will go out of its
way to destroy anybody for virtually any
reason so long as they do this I mean
Craig Ferguson back in the 2000s put up
a video of george w bush slurring his
words called him drunk and no but
care because everybody understood that
it was just a silly video you have a
random forklift driver who does this
about Nancy Pelosi and all hell breaks
loose bette midler today posted a brand
new face of it's a complete piece of
fake news about Donald Trump a fake
quote from him talking about how he was
gonna sucker the Republican Party she
posted that I'm very much looking
forward to seeing whether the media
investigate her and start revealing her
personal details about her life because
she had the temerity to post a piece of
news that wasn't true if your if your
target is Trump or people who support
some of his policies then it's okay you
can do you could do anything say
anything you have fake hate crimes you
can do it everyone I want to play The
Daily Beast Noah Shakman defending this
let's watch there's a profit motive here
that you can put up a lot of these
videos on Facebook you can make a quick
buck didn't this guy save me at $1,000
yeah I mean but look that's not it might
have been a lot of money to him but I
don't think it was a pure profit motive
I think for him it was a matter of
ideology it was you know he's a big
Trump supporter you don't need some
sophisticated operation in order to
publish fake news or publish of hoaxes
that'll grab the country's attention the
defenders of free expression always
always impressed
don't they then absolutely I mean I'm
just I'm so glad that no Shakman is out
there protecting us all you know and
President Trump says the enemy of the
people not a phrase have in love with
but I will say that when you're the
enemy of a forklift driver it's not a
good look all right Ben thanks so much
and I